the fake news trophy though we can't
give it to brian Stelter we can't give
it to Jim Acosta we can't give it a Jake
tap or we can't give it to any of those
guys the fake news Trophy winner this
month it has to go to Leanna English she
is the Obama holdover bureaucrat who is
now she's pretending to be the new
director of the Consumer Financial
Protection Bureau a particularly
unaccountable government agency that
shouldn't exist in the first place and
was established by senator Elizabeth
Warren of the Massachusetts tribe over
Mick Mulvaney the actual director named
by President Donald Trump for comment
let's turn to Senator Warren
[Music]
I have not I have not senator warren i
don't know why you would ask me CFPB
director Richard Cordray and Obama hold
over just resigned and he appointed
Leandre English another obama bureaucrat
as the director of the agency so far so
good
only trouble is he has no authority to
do that and so President Trump named
budget director Mick Mulvaney to run the
agency nevertheless the Democrats they
love just playing pretend especially in
government so the woman is just
pretending to be the director of this
this unaccountable agency now on his
first day by the way Mulvaney brought
dunkin donuts to the office so i think
we know who is going to go for him win
hearts and minds but at Leon drew
English I'm sure was waiting for
somebody else to bring her doughnuts
she's entitled to them obviously and
back to the agency the agents she
shouldn't exist the agency was proposed
by Elizabeth Warren before she became a
senator 2007-2008 it was authorized by
the dodd-frank permanent financial
cronyism Act of 2010 the agency's major
accomplishments in its seven years of
existence appear to have been enriching
trial lawyers and abusing black
employees one unit was nicknamed the
plantation because it comprised all
black employees and was subject to a
special abuse specific abuse one
employee called it a quote humiliating
experience said working for the CFPB is
quote a living hell it's apparently run
by intimidation and like a dictatorship
there are consequences for disagreeing
or disobeying the king all of their
words not mine
according to a Government Accountability
Office report one-quarter 25% of
minority employees of the CFPB reported
that they have been victims of
discrimination almost 1 in 10 employees
reported that they had been retaliated
against by a supervisor for calling
attention to the discrimination now none
of this is surprising by the way because
this is one of the major problems baked
into the agency this the the agency is
unaccountable it's an independent agency
Denis shawl there's a former aide to
Barney Frank that that's the law that
created the agency dodd-frank he
explained in an op-ed for The Wall
Street Journal last week that the CFPB
should just be shut down which it should
the CFPB is uniquely unaccountable he
rights it's an independent agency with a
sole director he who isn't even
accountable to the congressional
appropriations process so there are some
independent agencies like the Securities
and Exchange Commission the FCC the FTC
those are funded by Congress but the
CFPB is funded by the Federal Reserve so
that means it has precisely zero canned
retinal oversight
Shaul assails the position of CFPB chief
as quote a politically biased regulatory
dictator and a political stepping stone
for its sole director that is true as
directors now running for governor of
god-knows-where as an independent agency
the CFPB is supposed to be bipartisan
but while a lot of its employees donated
to Hillary Clinton 2016 not a single one
of them donated to president Trump's
campaign now what about the agency
itself what is it done the CFPB has been
useless and duplicative of other
services as you might expect it took
credit for other agencies and
corporations work like when the LA Times
uncovered fraud at Wells Fargo it
illegally as regulated industries
outside of its mandate it pays
significantly higher salaries and other
agencies that's how it got so bloated so
quickly it maintains a slush fund of
billions of dollars because its finances
lack any oversight and it's proposed
rules which luckily Congress intervened
to overrule would have devastated
industries even the CFPB's name is
propaganda it's a it's a Protection
Bureau Dodge Consumer Financial
Protection Bureau and the nice
regulatory Bureau government Bureau that
just doesn't have the same ring to it
now the agency is even pretending that a
left-wing stooge is its director rather
than the presidential a appointed one
that's because as President Reagan
pointed out one of the many bits of
brilliance he's bestowed on us a
government Bureau is the nearest thing
to eternal life on earth now the CFPB is
particularly egregiously unaccountable
it embodies everything that's wrong with
big government bureaucrats and so on
this is another holiday this will be the
the fake news trophy day congratulations
to the fake consumer financial fake
Protection Bureau interim director a
fake director
Leandra English you win this month's
fake news true